I also think the the whole idea of
venture capital there's a lot of venture
capitalists who are still confused that
a pure play media company is going to be
you know a billion dollar company and I
think what we're learning now just like
you figured out hey look the conferences
the webcam these other revenue sources
can be highly profitable for what they
are now we're gonna get into this world
where like the media companies figure
out other ways to monetize then just
like hey pay me some advertising and
I'll slap a you know banner ad somewhere
or whatever and what I haven't seen yet
that I think BuzzFeed maybe tried to do
this is I'm shocked no one's built a
media company and then went and built
products and then use their distribution
to pipe the products through yeah I
think BuzzFeed tried it but I don't know
how successful it was I'll tell you one
thing ultimately I don't care okay I
mean I don't think a lot about how to
build the next media empire and I think
that's why I was successful I truly
loved like what I did like the very
first few years I didn't I didn't think
about the business Heather did I mean I
talked about the business although that
was all my CEO so I hired a CEO because
I'm terrible at managing people she ran
the business she turned it into what it
was I was just I don't say I'm the
talent it sounds like I'm boasting but I
was literally just a guy who very
important call coming I was literally
just a guy who wrote content every day I
loved meeting founders I loved meeting
new understanding what their new
products were and that's just what I
love doing and I think obviously you
love what you're doing right I mean you
like talking to people so you obviously
spent a bunch of time interviewing
founders hundreds if not thousands of
them had that helped you when you got to
the investing side of the table a lot of
people owed me favors right I mean you
know for an entrepreneur that first
press is very important it's it can help
you hire it's your parents get to see it
your friends get to see it like it feels
good it feels more real and I was often
it's not usually the first person to
write about a startup and so that
generates a lot of camaraderie and
goodwill
and so that definitely helped when we
launched our venture fund get into some
of the early like really important deals
that really helped our first venture
fund like hit it out of the park and so
you know it's it's also just doing good
we'll get doing nice things for people
without any kind of transactional hope
for a payoff is actually like really
works out well in the end right you just
do what you love you help people and
you're going to find a way to be
successful from that and and if it's not
a transaction like some people are so
obviously transactional in the way they
deal with people that you know what I
mean by that you just sort of end up
being turned off by it all just tell
people like in a way that is fun to do
and it'll end up working out well it's
funny too because I think Silicon Valley
like literally the physical place more
so than probably anywhere else in the
business world understands that and I
think it's like the ball talks about you
know playing long-term games long-term
people or whatever the quote is and it
just feels like Silicon Valley has known
this for decades and people know they're
to run into each other again and so
people generally try to avenge so let's
just explore that for a minute I mean I
think it's really important so I rely I
realized once I got into crypto that
that is not how the whole world works so
in Silicon Valley we dealt with a lot of
New York people and your people have
their own special way of dealing with
people in business and not necessarily
negative you decide to be abrupt direct
right and you have to adjust to that in
New York people adjust to Silicon Valley
people but generally speaking like
people find a way in Silicon Valley to
work out their problems without like it
getting ugly I don't even know benchmark
sued uber a few years ago that was like
a sea change in Silicon Valley like you
just didn't see that I mean you saw it
very rarely with egregious examples of
malfeasance but like what uber did like
it was it was it was interesting that
benchmark sued them because that
reputational issue is important to them
when I got into crypto I realized very
suddenly that like a lot of players were
not in Silicon Valley or New York they
were in Europe and they were in Asia and
like completely different like cultures
right and
for anybody who spends a lot of time in
Asia you realize how different the
cultures in Asia are but like when you
deal with people from China Chinese
nationals
you have to like worry about things in a
certain way when you deal with people
from Singapore who are maybe Chinese
it's totally different Hong Kong again
totally different in Korea totally
different and so I had to learn very
quickly that people do business
differently and you have to watch
yourself because long-term reputations
didn't matter as much especially like
eighteen when we first started getting
involved in this in 2017 and it's a
really a problem in crypto because I
think a lot of people have almost like a
Napoleon complex I don't know how to put
it but like crypto was so hot in 2017
and it's become so mundane since then
and people like you and I believe it
will become very very hot again but in
the meantime I think people with these
very large egos aren't making any money
and they act in a certain way that's
just been disappointing to me yeah and I
think also you see this in finance right
etc is just like it's a very binary game
kind of zero-sum I win yeah and I think
also venture investing in general like
people who understand how it works
realize it doesn't have to be zero-sum
right yes maybe you lose it's not
zero-sum yeah yeah and so I think that
like just the asset and the way that the
investing is done definitely helps but
on top of that also if you think of
Silicon Valley like there is a scarcity
of great companies right and so everyone
is going to when they see great
companies and whatever stack of the of
the process they're going to come I
would not say I'd say there's a surplus
of capital okay yeah yes either way it's
either surplus a capital or scarcity to
companies but there's a mismatch between
the capital available and the number of
companies that that they should probably
get that
yeah right and that's not that's
probably not necessarily as true in the
finance world
maybe there's individual deals but it
there's definitely a very different
mindset without a doubt
well and the funny thing is you
eventually gravitate to people you like
doing businesses so you for example but
who's our sponsor today it's a block
fire because why -
amazing companies yeah Mike is opposite
expert in all things media and revenue
but block by a great company you have
been you're an investor in and you've
been like from the beginning right
pretty early yeah yeah your fund has put
like a big bet on block flying over
multiple rounds and and you introduced
him to me and we invested because of you
and it wasn't you for example trying to
resell your shares to me at triple the
price that you bought them which is a
situation I recently came across with
some Asian investors with a different
company that I won't mention called
Arabic and it was just a wonderful and I
also I assume you didn't get a kickback
from block 5 as part of that which
another company we just looked at it
turned out somebody else is getting a
person introduced to us was getting a
kick like all that stuff is just very
alien and ugly to me you simply liked
the company you thought I could add
value you thought it would be a good
investment for us you put us together we
made the investment and we love the
company and as far as I know you got
nothing out of that I hope except block
5 was again even more appreciative to
you and I've never heard a company gush
over someone the way they gushed over
you when we first talked to them so
they're incredibly kind but but I think
that your point about it's this weird
thing where you're lining up incentives
right like I knew that we were super
bullish on the company we were literally
making a very big investment I knew that
they were looking specifically for
certain types of help that we said look
we can help in one area but there's
other people who are much better than we
are
let's go get those people you happen to
be one of those people who brought very
specific value to it to what they needed
and when you line that up I think the
point around you know one you get a see
a deal you didn't previously see or
didn't spend much time on right and you
liked it so you're gonna do a deal they
look in and they say hey look we've got
this great investor being under our cap
table and for us it's one of these
things were like if you're not involved
in the deal like I would argue that the
deals upside potential is not as high as
it is with you in the deal right so what
yeah you you want people around the
table who you know can help because
those people will make everyone make
more money and also any girl it's not
Fairweather friends because because too
many people are fair
their friends nice eosin crypto as well
we're like when everything's hot you're
everybody's your best friend but
companies they really need their
investors when times are bad and if you
stick through a company when times are
bad they remember that and they tell
other people and and I'm not saying as
far as I know block fire hasn't had a
bad time yet but when they do you'll be
there for them and I'll be there for
them and and they'll remember that so
couldn't agree more